it's great to welcome to the program
today and rule a cough who's a
sociologist at the University of
Southern California also author of the
2017 book unprepared global health in a
time of emergency
great to have you Andrew thanks for
having me so yeah it's become very and
vogue now to point to you know Bill
Gates and his TED talk about at some
point we're going to have a pandemic
that were unprepared for and so on and
so forth and I think for our
conversation I want to focus in a little
more on on the nitty-gritty that you've
researched and and reported on and some
of the specifics maybe to start with we
can talk about this national stockpile
what are the origins of the national
stockpile what types of components are
there we we know of course about masks
and ventilators now but what's the kind
of genesis of that stockpile well
there's two parts to the story there the
very first idea of a stockpile of
essential supplies to be used in the
event of a catastrophic event took place
during the Cold War so the civil defense
agency built up stockpiles all around
the country of essential medical
supplies now by the 1970s those of
course hadn't been used fortunately we
never had a nuclear war that stockpile
was closed down but the idea was
rekindled in the 1990s in response to
the threat of a bioterrorism attack
officials in the Clinton administration
were worried that stockpiles of bio
agents like smallpox and anthrax that
had been accumulated in the Soviet Union
had gone missing and might be in the
hands of terrorists and they began to
think about the need for stockpiles of
biomedical countermeasures in the event
of such an attack so that really a got
put in place in the late 1990s in the
early 2000s and what what are examples
of specifics that are part of these
stockpiles so initially in response to
the threat of a bioterrorism attack a
lot of the elements of the stockpile
were specifically focused on possible
terror agents so there were nerve gas
antidotes there was millions of vials of
smallpox vaccine
anthrax vaccines so a lot of medications
in cold storage eventually antiviral
medications in preparation for pandemic
influenza
there also were non non pharmaceutical
supplies for example and there's been a
lot of discussion of this ventilators
protective equipment that kind of thing
when it comes to the ventilator I don't
even really want to call it a debate but
what was for a while
fear of a shortage and what I would
characterize is the federal government's
slow implementation of distributing I
mean I think that some of those
ventilators could have been distributed
far earlier at very little cost if they
end up not being necessary okay you send
them back what else sort of should flesh
out our understanding of the ventilator
piece specifically I mean in terms of
certainly creating new ones we know that
the manufacturing process is not you
have them in 48 hours we're kind of now
building up a supply which will be
manufactured over the next three months
but what what insight do you have into
the entire ventilator situation yeah the
I guess the to step back one to step
back a little bit the important thing to
keep in mind also is the process of
distribution so a lot of planning and
thought went into you know once you have
supplies available how do you decide
where they should go how do you get them
to the right places how do you keep
track of how many supplies of a given
item you have and where they are among
this the various stockpiles in different
parts of the country so one piece of the
story is of course do you have enough of
them and that's the question you asked
but another is how do you get them to
the places where they're needed yes and
and when it comes to that is it
unrealistic of me to think that in late
January or early February there were
likely the signals that would have
supported starting to deploy them to
urban areas in some way or is it
unrealistic to think that that would
have been an appropriate time to do it
to be proactive yeah an important part
of stockpile planning is to put in place
the stockpiles of items where they're
needed as soon as you get a signal that
there might be a disaster on the way so
that's right as the World Health
was putting every nation in the world on
alert in late January as officials were
beginning to counsel the administration
that there might be an epidemic of a
very dangerous disease on the way in
particular respiratory disease indeed
that would have been the time to start
figuring out whether we had enough
ventilators and whether they were in the
right place so one more thing on the
stockpile thing and then I want to move
on to a few other things Jared Kushner
had this very strange Orwellian moment
where he said the stockpile is our
stockpile it's not the state stockpile
what I didn't that I don't even know
what to make of that in the sense that
well everybody I guess unless you're in
Guam or Puerto Rico you're in one of the
states like at we are the states but is
there anything about the stockpiles
origin that makes that statement less
Orwellian well it's a very confused
statement it doesn't understand the
whole premise of how governmental
preparedness has to work in a federal
system that like the United States the
whole presumption of a system that is
run by the federal government is that
states would make requests of the
federal government for the items when
they need them and that there would be a
elaborate and sophisticated coordination
between the federal government and the
states so it's not a competition between
the federal government and the states
it's not that it's belongs to the
federal government or us whatever Jared
Kushner meant by us but rather the real
effort is to figure out what the states
need and how can we get that material to
them yeah elaborate and sophisticated is
not matching up in my mind with a lot of
a lot of what we've seen so let's what
are some other ways in which as a planet
we are sort of underprepared for this
type of hundred year pandemic that we're
experiencing now I mean we know we don't
have a vaccine but that's a process you
need to sequence the virus and then
there's a process to go through most
optimistically there'd be you know
emergency use vaccines available in the
fall for healthcare workers and then
we're looking at 2021 we talked about
the ventilator distribution component
although fortunately the actual shortage
in the US has been has been minimal what
are some other ways that were
fundamentally under prepared for dealing
with something like this well I think
what we've seen in the last couple of
months is that you could have pretty
elaborate and sophisticated preparedness
in place and in fact under the Obama
administration very detailed play books
were put together for each step of
coordinated response to a potential
dangerous epidemic or pandemic yes um
but if you know if you have those in
place but you don't know you've got the
plans or you're not a you're not aware
of the plans you haven't practiced them
or you even don't take them seriously
then when the actual event happens
you're not going to you're not going to
respond adequately but are there some
other bottlenecks that are very specific
in terms of I mean you know
international travel is very different
now than it was during the 1918 flu
pandemic and the speed with which the
pathogens can be moved around is a part
of it or what which systems are simply
not prepared to really deal with this at
the start yeah I mean I think that at
its really a variegated story around the
world I think you can you can look at
countries like South Korea or Germany
and see that although of course there's
not yet a vaccine and there's not even
as an effective medication there are
non-pharmaceutical interventions
especially combined with widespread
diagnostic testing that can do a decent
job of mitigating the disease threat I'm
obviously they can't cure it but so so
in certain countries that really have
thought carefully about how to do this
and have strong health systems in place
where it looks not so catastrophic um in
other parts of the world where you don't
have competent government government
leadership you don't have a really
strong health system you have a lot of
economic inequalities that's where we
see the catastrophic event unfolding one
of the things I've been pointing out is
that the virus has exposed the
underlying fragility of a lot of the
systems that sometimes feel very very
solid and you know we could find two
three months ago we could have found a
number of indicators of the American
economy that weren't great right I mean
huge inequality and wages have been
stagnant etc but by the traditional
measures the economy was humming along
quite well high consumer confidence low
unemployment high stock market etc the
fragility that is exposed by a complete
hundred and eighty degree turn around in
just a few weeks for me has been one of
the most stunning things and I don't
know that you know the the system we
have doesn't reward
Proactive it's not that profitable to be
proactive but that's been a huge thing
for me yeah no I completely agree not
only is the the health systems for
fragile the supply chain system is
fragile the security of what we call
essential workers is precarious one
thing that preparedness planners didn't
think a lot about was the how to deal
with the economic after effects of these
non-pharmaceutical interventions like
social distancing measures so I think
countries that have a much more
resilient economic system in place have
turned out to be much better prepared
than countries like ours that really
focused on efficiencies at the expense
of resilience that's interesting what we
know from a medical perspective with
that certain countries were far better
prepared South Korea certainly comes to
mind but what which are the countries
that economically were much better
prepared well I think country I would
say that countries in which it was taken
for granted that you would you would
actually provide stable income so you
look at some of the Western European
countries that have instead of
furloughing workers or laying off
workers have kept workers up pretty much
on the job and employed through
government payments I think you need a
you need a an assumption of a social
welfare system to pass that kind of
legislation in an emergency context
which is something we of course don't
have here are there other countries what
other countries are at the top of the
list in terms of dealing with the
medical part I mean what's happened in
South Korea is incredible they still
don't have 300 deaths deaths they don't
least they're under 300 deaths which is
just stunning given that their first
case was officially found within hours
of the first u.s. case Germany has done
well although they had a far larger
outbreak and and I think it was just a
little more advanced by the time they
got around to it there's a lot of debate
about what's happening in Sweden
certainly a higher death rate now but
you're sort of taking a bet that maybe
the subsequent waves won't be as deadly
because you'll have higher immunity we
just don't know my view is that we just
won't know that for a while what are the
other countries that medically have done
the best yeah and one thing I would
agree with you about the uncertainty
about the outcome in a place like Sweden
but one thing I would say is that
insofar as a
is being made that we're kind of
accidentally following the Swedish model
in Sweden they have made sure that the
health systems are strong and that
people you know will have available
medical care so it's one thing to to let
things go without a plan in place and
it's another thing to sort of carefully
keep things less shut down than
elsewhere when you know that you're
gonna be able to provide serious medical
care for those who do get sick I think
the other countries to look at very
carefully although of course they're
different situations than the United
States our East Asian countries so
Taiwan Singapore places that experienced
stars were very proactive early on in in
January putting in place testing systems
contact tracing systems isolation
practices in some cases closing down
schools and businesses early in another
case in other cases not but it looks
like they those countries have for the
most part weather this much better than
the United States has one of the ideas
that's floated about when we look at
some of these other countries is that we
can't really do what some of those
countries do because they are far more
authoritarian now with the case of South
Korea South Korea ranks higher than the
United States on the democracy index
only slightly so but but they do and
certainly to say that South Korea
handled it because they're an
authoritarian system of government seems
completely false when it comes to some
other places
is there anything to the idea that not
all of these measures would be tolerable
in the United States politically well I
think you know again just to add to your
point a place like Germany there's no
way you could make an argument that
contemporary Germany is more
authoritarian than the United States
yeah but it really has to do with
competency trust and expertise proactive
government intervention and trust by the
public in that intervention so it's not
so much a question of authoritarian
versus democratic but when you have a
when you have a liberal democratic
country what kind of system do you need
to have in place which of course we had
we had planned for such a system here
that wouldn't invade fundamental rights
the problem is we didn't implement that
plan last thing I want to touch on going
forward there may be a second
and third wave there may just be a
second one this first wave may never
really diminish and it may sort of go
into the time where we would potentially
have a second wave we don't know the
timeline for a wide widely available
vaccine we don't exactly know when any
of the 70 or 80 possible treatments may
turn up to work very effectively there's
economic concerns we still aren't
testing enough what are you looking at
and what would be the the lowest hanging
fruit to do over the next six months
well I think what we what we're
obviously going to have a period of
trial and error over the next six months
as we figure out what works and what
doesn't work because obviously we won't
have a vaccine in that period or very
it's very unlikely we would I think what
we need what what I'm looking at is just
the extent to which we're not flying
blind as we go forward how much are we
actually tracking what's going on and
proactively intervening before things
get bad again each time we try to lessen
our social distancing measures so the
more information we have the better and
the more that information ties into
actual rapid policy decisions the better
outcome we'll have are the over the next
few months so it sounds like at an
absolute minimum
no matter what the trajectory is going
to be if we don't have dramatically more
testing we are going to be short on the
information we need to really make
informed decisions I think that's right
we need more we need a dramatically more
testing but we also need to new to know
what we're going to do with the results
of those tests we actually need a plan
that links tests to policies so it's not
just the testing but also acceptance of
guidelines from from a central
coordinated government effort that will
lead to less bad outcomes we've been
speaking with Andrew lay cough
sociologist at the University of
Southern California also author of the
book unprepared global health in a time
of emergency Andrew I really appreciate
your time today thanks for having me
here